[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP l'émission on
parle cuisine alimentation agriculture
mais aussi politique et cette semaine
nous recevons Frédéric Valtou bonjour
bonjour et avec moi pour présenter cette
émission Jean-Pierre Montanet bonjour
Jean-Pierre bonjour Brigitte bonjour
Frédéric valtour vous êtes député
horizon de Seine-et-Marne vous avez été
maire de Fontainebleau de 2005 à 2022 la
politique vous l'avez côtoyé très tôt
mais de l'autre côté de la barrière en
tant que journaliste d'abord à la
Gazette des communes puis vous saisissez
pendant 10 ans au journal Les Échos
votre bureau était paraît-il situé près
du bar mais c'est un ami viticulteur qui
le dit peut-on lui faire confiance
j'oubliais vous avez également été
président de la FHF la Fédération
hospitalière de France pendant 11 ans
alors Jean-Pierre au menu un plat sain
et hypocalorique comme le prévoit
l'ordonnance du docteur Henry célèbre
chirurgien Brestois ou plutôt un repas
plus traditionnel vous qui êtes à
Fontainebleau habitué à la vie de
château
de veau et en dessert un Fontainebleau
dans le dessous des plats le local à la
cote le village potager nourrit quelques
500 familles de Seine-et-Marne alors
reportage dans cette émission dans les
pieds dans plat la réforme des retraites
vue des campagnes quel changement pour
les ouvriers agricoles et les
agriculteurs explications à suivre allez
on passe à table tout de suite cuisine
et confidence
je sais que vous avez longtemps hésité
avant de choisir une blanquette de veau
certes c'était le choix de votre cœur ce
plat fédérateur de ces grandes tablées
familiales
intergénérationnelles à Fontainebleau
une recette séculaire qui a fait ses
preuves donc une valeur sûre mais
justement un peu trop sûr trop pépère
pour certains qui jugent que le signal
envoyé avec la blanquette et ringard
hazebeen alors c'est même grincheux à
Brigitte plaid pour plus d'audace de
fantaisie avec des Macron mi-cuit au
pickles des carpaccio de betteraves ou
des fidèles canard au yuzu mais en fait
Brigitte le visionnaire c'est vous
Frédéric valtoux car la blanquette
incarne comme la poule au pot le chou
farci les quenelles de brochet le retour
en force de la cuisine bourgeoise
gourmande sans chichi roborative mais
comme Monsieur Jourdain qui faisait de
la prose sans l'imaginer vous nous
dessinez peut-être des tendances de la
cuisine sans même le savoir à moins que
ce soit vraiment le must à table pour
vous la blanquette alors elle est
comment cette blanquette et ben je
goûter mais en tout cas à l'oeil elle a
l'air parfaite elle a l'air très bien
alors pourquoi ce choix en fait c'est
véritablement un plat familial un plat
traditionnel que vous mangez quand vous
étiez petit à la maison c'est aussi un
plat que j'ai fait de temps en temps à
mes enfants et comme j'en ai 5 mais ça
fait des grandes tablés on m'a dit le
seul plat que vous savez faire alors je
fais quelques autres mais je suis pas un
grand cuisinier non plus donc mais ça
c'est quelque chose
ce qui est bien avec ta blanquette c'est
qu'on peut aussi l'accommoder selon les
envies avec des légumes un peu
différents etc donc c'est pas finalement
un plastifigé que ça d'abord c'est un
plat qui quand on le sert dans les
restaurants il y a pas toujours la même
nom de tête on va dire et vous vous la
revisiter de temps en temps alors je la
revisite modestement moi je suis enfin
voilà avec un peu des poireaux parfois
là je vois qu'il y avait sûrement du riz
parce que c'est vrai que c'est du riz
mais du riz avec aussi des poireaux avec
des carottes et là il y a pas de
poireaux mais les carottes voilà bon
bref en tout cas c'est qu'elle est
pommes de terre on peut aussi ouais bien
sûr mais voilà c'est un plat simple
et puis c'est un plat qui est longue
histoire et en même temps qui n'a pas de
racine c'est à dire il est très français
et et donc
il a pas des racines régionales d'accord
parce que tout le monde le revendique un
peu le la blanquette
etc
le berceau de l'enquête mais en fait
c'est un plat très voilà c'est pour le
coup il est très français consensuel
consensuel
et surtout si elle est aussi bonne que
la vôtre alors elle est sans doute
meilleure parce que je veux vraiment je
suis un modeste cuisinier alors c'est
chez Françoise qu'on remercie évidemment
qui nous a cuisiné cette cette bonne
blanquette mais Jean-Pierre dites-nous
quand même trois astuces pour bien
réussir sa
blanquettement je peux peut-être obser
sa blanquette il écoute mes conseils
alors il faut d'abord faire blanchir la
viande alors faire la blanchir ça veut
dire là la mettre dans de l'eau froide
pour ensuite la porter à ébullition mais
on peut même commencer à la faire un peu
revenir avec un peu de farine ensuite
mettre de l'eau et la faire bouillir
ensuite vous écumer pour enlever toutes
les petites traces les imp vous avez une
viande bien tendre et bien blanche qui
va être meilleur ensuite il faut faire
un bouillon goûte alors ça il faut
couper des oignons lamelles un des
carottes Onet
effectivement la méthode petite bouchée
deux carrés de bouillon et puis voilà
mais on peut faire avec des poireaux des
carottes vous les faites revenir dans un
fait tout et vous là vous faites cuire
assez longtemps près de deux heures et
là vous avez ensuite vous écumer vous
passez au chinois vous gardez que le
bouillon pas les légumes et puis ensuite
il faut monter à la fin cette sauce
blanche avec le bouillon c'est le moment
le plus délicat là je dois dire que
quand on est à un patiner sur le dîner
c'est le moment le plus délicat il faut
faire une petite montée de stress ce qui
est très agréable vous voyez c'est que
pendant la préparation comme ça cuit
longtemps il y a une odeur aussi et
finalement l'odeur ça fait partie aussi
de la alors
c'est comme une béchamel mais c'est pas
de lait c'est de l'eau et de la farine
et du beurre et puis ensuite on va
rajouter un petit peu de cette eau de
bouillon et avec un fouet on va un petit
peu monter et puis à la fin et bien on
peut même rajouter un offre pour faire
monter cette petite sauce et la mêler
délicatement au plat et servir tout de
suite la blanquette voilà c'est comme ça
que vous la faites tout est dit à peu
près comme ça on va dire à peu près
comme ça mais le résultat il est très
bien ah le mien c'est mais c'est vrai
que cette dernière phase elle est
compliquée enfin elle est compliquée
quelqu'un qui a un cuisinier je le redis
c'est c'est un moment sensible alors
s'il y a pas de blanc qui a été il y a
d'autres plats que vous savez cuisiner
c'est des plats simples
[Musique]
je sais nourrir une famille je sais pas
forcément l'emmener vers des
extravagances culinaires incroyables non
je je déplace simple et puis mais j'ai
quand même besoin je suis pas très
imaginatif j'ai quand même besoin d'une
recette bien faite oui j'ai pas mal de
livres de cuisine chez moi j'ai pas mal
de livres de cuisine et en douce je
jette un coup d'oeil et que j'ai besoin
qu'on me guide qu'est-ce qui vous
inspire vous êtes guidé par quoi vous
êtes vous êtes audacieux temps en temps
sur les cuisines un peu étrangères ou
pas du tout Français
parce que
je considère après c'est beaucoup trop
compliqué à faire non après c'est des
plats je sais pas des viandes du lapin
et vous prenez un peu de plaisir
mais voilà mais je cuisine pas de
manière enfin régulière c'est plus
facile vous êtes quelqu'un gourmand de
gourmet de par contre je ne fais pas les
desserts ça je non ça je les achète où
je les laisse faire à d'autres mais oui
je suis assez oui oui je suis assez
gourmet gourmand ouais ouais j'aime bien
mais vous courrez les bons petits
restaurants les bonnes petites adresses
ou finalement manger c'est un peu se
nourrir et ça va pas au-delà non pour
moi manger c'est un moment vraiment de
convivialité où on peut se poser
tranquillement passer du temps avec les
gens discuter donc si évidemment si le
plat est bon ça ajoute à la convivialité
du moment mais voilà c'est pas j'ai pas
m'extasier pendant une heure devant un
bon plat à regarder le photographe 500
km pour aller manger un bon moment
moi j'aime bien les restaurants plus
évidemment pour l'assiette mais plus
pour l'ambiance donc la bistronomie par
exemple c'est quelque chose qui vous qui
vous convient peu d'ambiance
et la nourriture ça voilà on l'emmène
dans l'ambiance quoi c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas ce qui me fait courir dans un
restaurant alors vous avez été maire de
Fontainebleau pendant 17 ans donc vous
avez arrêté pour cause de cumul de
mandat pendant 17 ans quand on émerge
j'imagine qu'on arpente un peu quand
même les le marché le week-end vous
connaissez tous les les producteurs du
coin vous vous allez choisir vos
produits sur le marché vous regardez un
peu oui vous les connaissez vous faites
les courses oui je fais les courses
c'est l'occasion
alors je fais la cuisine que le week-end
mais quand j'ai le temps donc c'est
pratique tous les dimanches ah oui tous
les dimanches entre tous marchés je le
fais pas je suis au marché pour me laver
pour rencontrer les gens parce que c'est
quand même le moment c'est comme dans
toutes les petites villes où les voilà
c'est le moment où tout le monde se
phrase en plus quand il fait beau il y a
des terrasses autour les gens aiment
bien prendre du temps etc donc c'est
sympa et vous êtes expert sur les
légumes les fruits vous savez exactement
ce que vous demandez vous avez là aussi
une petite liste
j'ai au feeling et puis j'essaye comme
quand on émerve même voilà on essaie de
se répartir c'est à dire je veux pas
toujours chez les mêmes manière à
pouvoir effectivement tourner un petit
côté politique oui pas politique mais
comme je sais bah après je sais que ce
sont des gens de qualité on il y a pas
mal de producteurs locaux aussi qui sont
sur le marché de Fontainebleau donc des
gens qui font qui voilà qui sont
eux-mêmes les qui produisent même ce
qu'ils vendent les légumes etc un fruit
donc oui oui non je je tourne j'ai pas
j'ai pas mes petites habitudes non mais
c'est très sympa mais il y a une bonne
il y a une bonne ambiance et puis moi
quand j'étais mère j'avais veillé à ce
que il y ait aussi des marchands
d'huîtres qui s'installent avec la
possibilité effectivement de boire
manger des huiles boire un verre de
déguster sur place et tout ça donne
beaucoup de convivialité et donc c'est
important aussi un marché c'est pas
juste un endroit où on va acheter bien
sûr ça reste ça mais c'est aussi un
endroit où on aime passer du temps quand
l'ambiance est là et on s'installe dans
les cafés etc et puis je vous dis c'est
le dimanche matin les gens sont détendus
pas trop pas trop agressif avec avec
leurs élus donc c'est bien on discute de
choses sympathiques et on prend
un certain nombre de choses pour
améliorer la première fois j'ai entendu
la phrase Monsieur le Maire je sais bien
qu'on m'ait dit qu'on est dimanche mais
quand même croyez pas que le trou qui
est là et la rue qui est machin et un
peu plus de propreté là ça serait mieux
etc bon voilà mais ça fait ils prennent
la précautionatoire de dire
quand j'étais quand les enfants étaient
plus jeunes j'étais avec les enfants
alors je vous êtes en famille je vais
pas vous embêter longtemps quand même
enfin quand même puisque vous êtes là il
faut quand même que je vous dise que bon
alors là on vous voit déguster une bière
là aujourd'hui nous avons du Meursault
alors un petit mot sur le morceau qui
est un des grands vins de Bourgogne qui
est dans la côte des des blancs avec le
poulini ou le Chassagne c'est un Côte de
Beaune donc on est situé pas très loin
de en Côte-d'Or pas très loin de Dijon
le sol est argile au calcaire
l'appellation c'est une AOC Meursault
cont il est blanc parce qu'il est
quasiment tout le temps blanc il peut
être rouge aussi quand il est blanc
c'est du Chardonnay bien sûr mais quand
il est rouge c'est du pinot noir et il a
cette couleur assez particulière un peu
jaune serein avec des reflets argentés
nous disent les grands spécialistes
viticoles il est élevé en fût de chêne
et c'est un millésime 2020 qu'on vous
propose là il est assez riche et assez
gras et ça se marie très bien donc bon
choix ça se marie très bien avec les
plats à base de crème notamment et voilà
c'est un plaisir aussi de déguster un
bon petit verre de vin avec un plat
quand on est gourmet quand on est
gourmand même si on voilà même si je
suis pas un grand connaisseur je
pourrais pas faire des dégustations à
l'aveugle par exemple mais oui oui bien
sûr que le vin c'est ça fait partie de
la convivialité et voilà de ce moment
qu'on apprécie vous avez une cave vous
mettez un peu du vin mais j'ai pas voilà
je suis je suis loin d'être un grand un
grand un grand et autant Bordeaux
Bourgogne
j'ai une préférence pour les Bourgogne
mais je suis bon public alors Brigitte
je suis moins expert que sur le vin moi
j'aurais spontanément intuitivement du
rouge sur la blanquette non et en fait
ça se marie très bien le blanc on peut
je me rapprocher de l'accord des
couleurs en fait on dit souvent que un
plat qui est plutôt clair doit s'adapter
avec un vin qui est plutôt blanc et en
fait donc ça se marie très bien on
aurait pu penser qu'avec le blanc
boivent du poisson on mange du poisson
avec du vin blanc mais en réalité un
plat à base de crème comme ça avec du
veau avec une volaille ça se marie très
bien mais c'est vrai qu'un rouge est
très bien aussi mais très bien
alors on va voir si vous êtes vraiment
incollable c'est le quiz
alors on l'a dit vous êtes l'ex-merde
Fontainebleau vous êtes donc incollable
sur ce fameux roi François 1er qui a
reconstruit et habité le château de la
ville un an avant d'être sacré monarque
en 1515 il se mariait avec Claude de
France fille de Louis XII les
affirmations suivantes sont-elles vrais
ou fausses elles concernent ce fameux
dîner de mariage alors ah l'un des mes
principaux servis lors de ce repas était
une pintade au foie doigt vrai ou faux
ça doit être vrai ça sonne vrai
en dessert le roi qui était un fan
d'Italie c'est régalé d'un tiramisu ça
je pense que c'est faux oui c'est faux
parce que le tiramisu
oreille selon une légende urbaine
réclamait des coins car c'est son fruit
préféré vrai ou faux
allez je vais dire vrai sans trop
d'assurance
et enfin des pour la première fois lors
de ce dîner de mariage des assiettes ont
fait leur apparition sur la table
de la Renaissance
[Musique]
sur une ou deux questions
oui sa que le 23 août 1603 un autre roi
Henri IV a promulgué un édit ordonnant
qu'un aliment soit désormais cultivé en
France de quel aliment s'agit-il à la
pomme de terre B le riz c'est
l'aubergine et des le maïs je dirais
l'aubergine alors non ah bah voilà alors
en fait ça colle avec le repas de rue
c'est le riz
venait d'Asie d'accord en Europe il est
arrivé par les plaines du pot en Italie
et les plaines de Hongrie et c'est c'est
Henri IV qui a décidé que le riz donc si
on mange du riz aujourd'hui du riz de
Camargue notamment c'est grâce à Henri
IV et l'aubergine est venue beaucoup
plus tard parce qu'au début c'était une
plante elle est devenue comestible
quasiment au début du 20e siècle Henri
IV qui a beaucoup aimé Fontainebleau oui
et qui a beaucoup transformé ce château
alors en France on sait que le repas
occupe une assez large place et
particulièrement en politique c'est
souvent là que ce nous les grandes
histoires et du coup c'est la brève de
comptoir
on vous a demandé Frédéric Valtou de
réfléchir à une anecdote autour d'un
repas si possible en politique est-ce
qu'il y en a une qui vous est revenu à
l'idée
j'ai été 15 ans journaliste et j'ai donc
beaucoup aussi pratiquer les déjeuners
et notamment je suis un art avec Alain
Madelin qui m'avait assez sidéré parce
que
pendant les premières vingt minutes il
avait plongé ses mains dans le pot de
cacahuètes qui étaient là il avait mangé
des cacahuètes comme ça et pendant on
est bien resté 20 minutes c'est
peut-être exagéré mais au moins 10
minutes à le regarder parce qu'il
parlait pas et puis il s'est mis à
discuter après bon ça c'est une anecdote
plus ancienne c'est pas très
gastronomique parce que les cacahuètes
c'était pas terrible mais il était comme
ça il était dans son truc à l'époque il
était ministre voilà histoire non
récemment je pense à un déjeuner parce
que c'était un moment où déjeunait plus
beaucoup c'était après les confinements
le covid etc et je trouve que pendant
ces périodes vous l'avez dit aussi j'ai
été président de la Fédération
hospitaire de France j'ai beaucoup
travaillé avec Brigitte Macron qui
elle-même préside toujours la Fondation
des hôpitaux de France et elle s'était
beaucoup mobilisé pour venir en aide et
pour récolter des fonds qui sont venus
en aide aux hôpitaux pendant notamment
le premier confinement et elle avait
beaucoup travaillé ensemble en leur par
téléphone par visio etc puisque c'est
comme ça qu'on travaillait elle elle
avait des dons spontanément il fallait
qu'on trouve des à des dépenser donc et
puis elle m'avait gentiment invitée à
déjeuner après toute sa scène qu'on a pu
se revoir mais c'était quand même à
déjeuner où on prenait encore des
précautions donc on avait beau être
dehors
à l'Elysée on avait une grande table il
y avait deux collaborateurs qui étaient
tout au bout et elle elle était un coin
et moi un autre mais bon parce que on
était très éloignés mais c'était en tout
cas très sympathique comme moment
puisque c'était voilà pour remercier de
la bonne collaboration qu'on avait eu
pendant les mois les difficiles donc
c'était un retour au repas et je me
voyais ça
exactement exactement
je me souviens des moments je me
souviens des ambiants je me souviens une
conversation je suis pas tellement
souvenir beaucoup
mais j'ai bien mangé
donc vous rencontriez des hommes
politiques aujourd'hui c'est un peu
l'inverse j'imagine que il y a des
journalistes qui veulent déjeuner avec
vous ça vous fait bizarre d'être de
l'autre côté de la barrière on pourrait
dire
oui oui forcément d'abord j'ai beaucoup
aimé ces 15 ans de de journaliste
oui ça fait c'est différent mais
finalement on parle voilà de la chose
publique on parle de sujets qui sont qui
sont intéressants on parle de mais c'est
oui oui c'est c'est un autre exercice
enfin maintenant c'était à 17 ans donc
c'est un vieux souvenir mais vous avez
davantage pesté contre les hommes
politiques quand vous étiez journaliste
ou maintenant que vous êtes politique ou
pestez contre les journalistes je peste
jamais contre les journalistes parce que
peut-être comme j'ai fait ce métier je
sais quels sont les difficultés les
contraintes c'est aussi un métier qui a
qui a beaucoup évolué je sais la
pression à l'information et puis il a
monté en puissance des réseaux sociaux
il faut aller vite faut sortir le truc
vite il faut faire quand on est presse
écrite un pour le papier du demain du
lendemain mais en même temps pour le
site internet etc voilà je donc c'est
pas un boulot facile et moi je suis je
voilà je suis assez
respectueux de du travail qui est pas
qui est pas simple je sais qu'il est pas
simple
toujours toujours même quand je sais pas
je dis je sais pas c'est pas grave mes
poches prends soin de répondre ouais
parce que c'est pénible aussi j'aimais
pas trop qu'on me répond pas quand
j'étais journaliste et qu'on laisse mes
appels mais quand on est journaliste on
a toujours l'impression que les hommes
politiques savent tout et qu'en fait ils
nous cache des choses qui pourraient pas
nous dire est-ce que quand on est de
l'autre côté de la barrière on dit
finalement bah parfois on ne sait pas
parce que en fait on peut pas informer
tout le monde des décisions qui sont
prises alors d'abord moi je oui alors
moi je parle assez facilement alors
après il y a des choses que je je je
veux pas dire parce que voilà ça ça peut
concerner d'autres mais
je parle assez facilement oui non non on
cache pas qu'il y ait de choses qu'on
cache enfin après moi je suis pas ni
prise en main public du ministre ou soit
donc j'ai pas je réalise de la défense
j'aurais peut-être des informations très
confidentielles
alors vous le savez les habitudes de
consommation ont changé les Français ne
jurent plus que par le local c'est le
dessous des plats
le bio mais surtout le local le village
potager créé en 2018 en Seine-et-Marne a
développé les circuits courts 200 tonnes
de légumes cultivés par an de quoi
nourrir quelques 500 familles en
Île-de-France une aventure familiale
mais aussi le début d'une seconde vie
professionnelle pour Hélène et Étienne
Pierre Miquel Carniel et Marion de
vauchelle les ont rencontrées
donc là on a un tunnel de blettes il y a
5 ans Hélène et Étienne était encore
cadre dans le quartier d'affaires de La
Défense ils ont complètement changé de
vie pour se lancer dans le maraîchage
depuis 2018 ils ont créé 35 emplois sur
leur site c'est un métier fantastique
parce que c'est un métier qui crée plein
d'emplois par définition c'est des
emplois locaux c'est aussi des emplois
qui font du bien évidemment quand on est
dans le bio dans l'agroécologie ben
c'est un boulevard en terme d'impact
environnemental
détaillée on livre à peu près 200 tonnes
de légumes par an 200 tonnes de légumes
de quoi nourrir plus de 500 familles
alors ces poireaux ils seront vendus
principalement en local et en Ultra
local donc à la ferme sur la
circonscription de Nemours de
Fontainebleau et puis sur sur la région
parisienne
après une heure de route et autant
passer dans les bouchons les poireaux du
village potager arrivent à Paris ils
finissent sur les étals de ce
supermarché du centre-ville et
l'enseigne ne fonctionne qu'en circuit
court
c'est 1 effectivement de nos principaux
fournisseurs on a pas mal de producteurs
locaux donc qui travaillent en
Île-de-France et aussi dans un rayon
majeur de 250 km autour de Paris et donc
le fait d'être proche de Paris permet de
faire moins d'aller-retours en camion
dépenser moins d'énergie et se retrouver
avec un environnement local qui
travaille et qui vit bien en harmonie en
harmonie il faut comprendre moins de
transport pour les produits plus de bio
et une meilleure rémunération pour les
producteurs on va leur rendre plusieurs
fois sur l'exploitation on essaie de
travailler sur l'exploitation avec eux
pendant des demi-journées de comprendre
leurs enjeux on est interdépendants les
uns des autres donc on se voit beaucoup
on échange beaucoup et on partage en
socle de valeur assez fort en commun
donc ça permet de voilà de construire le
projet et d'avancer ensemble sereine
malgré toutes ces initiatives reste
qu'en Île-de-France 9 produits
alimentaires sur 10 sont importés une
autre région
Frédéric Walto est-ce que vous
connaissez cette initiative de
seine-et-marnement oui je les connais
bien et d'ailleurs ils sont sur le
marché de Fontainebleau je disais que le
marché tout à l'heure était ouvert aussi
au producteurs locaux et on a ouvert ce
qu'on appelle un carré des producteurs
ou vraiment avec que du local que du
local que du local qui est une partie du
marché où les gens savent parce que on
l'a on l'a
identifié identifié voilà
mais la communication autour donc les
gens savent que là ils trouvent des
producteurs qui viennent dans un rayon
de 50 km 40 km donc des producteurs
locaux effectivement et ils en font
partie lui là je potage en fait une
initiative assez intéressante
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont complètement
changé de vie ils étaient cadres à la
défense et ils se retrouvent là les
pieds dans la terre vous vous comprenez
comment on peut comme ça qu'on puisse
avoir envie de changer complètement de
vie de se lancer dans quelque chose
c'est pas nouveau je pense que ça c'est
accéléré ces dernières années mais vous
auriez pu filmer aussi à quelques
kilomètres du village potager il y a une
une femme qui a quitté l'industrie à 40
ans qui s'est formé a fait un CAP de
boulangerie et qui fait de la
boulangerie bio qui est très dans un
village un tout petit village qui avait
plus de commerce qu'elle a réouvert ça
et elle a changé de vie complètement
voilà c'est un autre exemple il y en a
beaucoup en ce moment effectivement qui
qui retourne vers des métiers de de
production de donc là les agriculteurs
change en fait alors c'est pas un
mouvement mais c'est pas massif mais
quand même c'est intéressant ils
viennent d'un tout autre ils sont
inspirés par le sens il draine alors eux
ils traînent le village potager il
drague beaucoup de jeunes ils ont
beaucoup d'apprentis et ils ont beaucoup
de jeunes qui viennent ils forment en
même temps
il disait qu'ils étaient ils avaient
créé un certain nombre d'emplois mais
au-delà de ça ils forment beaucoup de
jeunes qui effectivement soit veulent se
lancer soit font une allée de césure et
veulent se frotter un peu au métier
agricoles de demain là qui sont
pépinière aussi peut-être et puis des
jeunes qui s'interrogent aussi peut-être
sur leur avenir et qui veulent voir à
quoi ça qu'est-ce que c'est que des
dragiculteurs donc ça marche très bien
en retraite d'agricul là à l'horizon
2030 la moitié à peu près vous pensez
qu'elle suffisamment justement
d'agriculteurs qui qui se lancent et qui
pourront assurer finalement de pour
faire manger toute la population de en
tout cas il se lance et puis on voit de
plus en plus de diversification on est
dans une région le sud Seine-et-Marne
qui est vraiment une région très
céréalière avec des grands domaines
enfin c'est bon mais on voit quand même
de plus en plus d'exploitation de
maraîchage ou effectivement de ou même
de diversification et donc on voit
évoluer les paysages aussi quand on voit
évoluer on voit évoluer
d'autres cultures et donc d'autres
approches de l'agriculture aussi moins
intensifs peut-être qu'ils ont très une
forte idée de l'environnement alors la
conservation de notre planète sans doute
une génération qui amène aussi une
préoccupation liée à l'environnement qui
est plus forte et donc on voit des
pratiques qui évoluent on voit des
jeunes de plus en plus qui s'intéressent
alors ils testent il reste où il reste
pas mais en tout cas ils regardent ils
font
je connais des gens qui font la
permaculture aussi qui beaucoup de qui
voient passer beaucoup de CV de qui
prennent des jeunes en apprentissage etc
donc c'est énorme s'il y a un mouvement
qui est intéressant ça reste malgré tout
le sud Seine-et-Marne toute cette région
très très céréalières mais voilà on voit
des choses qu'on ne voyait plus à voyait
pas il y a 10 ans il y a aussi après
pour le local depuis le covid les gens
vont soit directement producteur soit
sur le carré là de votre marché à
Fontainebleau pourquoi votre avis c'est
pour se rapprocher des agriculteurs pour
aider les petits commerces vous voyez ça
comment vous
oui je crois qu'il y a une envie de de
sens il y a une envie de revenir à une
saisonnalité aussi des produits qu'on
achète on a il y a une envie de revenir
à une
consommation qui est moins
mas market enfin qui est moins
industriels donc oui et puis il y a
cette compréhension effectivement que
acheter local c'est aider des
agriculteurs proches les boutiques à la
ferme se multiplient
dans le sud Seine-et-Marne dans la
circonscription
et moi j'ai plein d'agriculteurs qui
ouvrent des boutiques il y en a encore
un qui a fait ça il y a deux mois qui
est un éleveur et qui a ouvert et donc
il s'est installé un atelier de découpe
et ils vont sous vide et ils vont sous
vide ou pas sous vide d'ailleurs enfin
ils vont
se déplacer du coup à la ferme
en même temps ils vont la bière du bras
de la brasserie du coin ils vont les
œufs qui sont en quelques kilomètres et
donc finalement c'est une micro épicerie
et et quand les gens se baladent de
faire enfer mais ben finalement
discute avec les producteurs ils
visitent en même temps les les fermes
donc ça marche pas mal moi je circule
souvent là-bas c'est vrai ce que dit
Monsieur Valtou on est tout le temps
vente directe à la faire fromage
exactement et on s'arrête il y a
toujours ils sont assez malins parce
qu'il y a toujours une petite aire de
Paris où on peut même rentrer dans la
cour de la ferme bien sûr et là avant
c'était un peu austère la vente directe
aujourd'hui ils font même des plats
préparés des conserves etc ils ont dopé
c'est vrai un vrai levier de croissance
c'est pour ces mêmes alors il y a de la
vente à la ferme et puis aussi on envoie
de plus en plus des distributeurs ça
c'est pour les gens qui rentrent tard à
toutes les heures il y a des
agriculteurs de produits frais et qui
mettent à l'entrée de leur de leur ferme
ou de ou même j'en connais un à
bagneaux-sur-cagneaux-sur-loing qui est
en dessous de Nemours à la gare de
Bagneux vous avez effectivement
une
distributeur automatique qui est
approvisionnée par un agriculteur de de
qui est proche et qui vient tous les
jours remettre etc et les gens peuvent
acheter directement c'est génial à la
ferme mais il trouve pas de produits des
produits locaux
alors c'est plutôt des produits de la
ferme il y a pas de faire ma pizza
j'en sais rien alors il y avait du bio
aussi chez au village potager et le bio
en revanche on voit que ça chute
fortement que les gens n'achètent plus
de bio pour des raisons essentiellement
financières
comment on fait pour aider le bio et ce
qu'il faut le relancer ce qu'il faut là
il y a un plan qui se prépare au
ministère de l'Agriculture il faut
fonctionner massivement
considérer qu'on est sans doute après le
covid et peut-être que le covid enfin le
confinement le le tout ce qui s'est
passé depuis deux ans a peut-être aussi
voilà poussé le bio puis il y a quand
même une question de pouvoir d'achat
aujourd'hui qui est quand même prégnante
donc c'est vrai que le bio pour
l'instant reste légèrement plus cher sur
c'est un produit en tout cas que le le
produit traditionnel enfin donc un
problème de pouvoir d'achat c'est vrai
que les gens se sont habitués à
consommer depuis beaucoup enfin ces
dernières années pas très cher est-ce
que finalement c'était pas le vrai prix
de l'alimentation est-ce que aujourd'hui
pour avoir une bonne alimentation
qui soit produit en France en local il
faut admettre de payer un peu plus on a
poussé vraiment depuis des dizaines
d'années on a poussé la tendance à
effectivement comme on dit des prix
vraiment tirés vers le bas et qu'on
comprend bien que les agriculteurs ne
peuvent plus tenir avec ces prix tirés
vers le bas et donc aujourd'hui il y a
des tensions très fortes effectivement
de la montre la grande distribution et
les filières de production parce que
parce que sans doute on n'est pas voilà
il y a on n'est pas au juste prix et que
ce recalage les gens le font mais les
gens le font aussi parce que ils
préfèrent sans doute aujourd'hui par
exemple manger moins de viande mais
manger de la meilleure viande manger et
ce sera vrai pour tous les produits donc
pareil pour les légumes pour les fruits
etc donc je pense que le bio c'est
conjoncturel on est dans des ajustements
aussi de de marché
voilà après il y a des gens qui sont des
des passionnés qui font du tout bio en
permanence bon est-ce que pour le mieux
c'est pas aussi un acte citoyen parce
que de toute façon ça coûte plus cher
pour le paysan donc comme si vous dites
il faut le rémunérer il faut se dire que
c'est un acte un peu militant citoyen
pour notre planète pour les agriculteurs
parce qu'on est c'est entre 20 et 50%
voire 100% plus cher le bio oui c'est ça
restera toujours plus cher mais
maintenant pardon mais on voit beaucoup
de choses industrielles qui sont qui
sont
maquis des labels
la compréhension je pense que ça devient
compliqué vous allez dans un rayon de
yaourt mais en supermarché il y a marqué
bio sur la moitié des yaourts et je suis
pas sûr que on soit vraiment dans des
canons de production qui a aussi de la
baie bio aussi
en tout cas j'ai l'impression que
parfois les gens s'y perdent j'ai
l'impression parfois les gens s'y
perdent non je pense que au-delà au-delà
du BIOS qui moi je regarde de plus près
c'est ce qu'on évoque c'est-à-dire ce
retour au circuit court à l'achat direct
chez les producteurs et moi je le vois
pardon de reprendre cet exemple mais
l'exemple de du marché de Fontainebleau
le carré des producteurs qu'on qu'on a
fait marche très bien et les gens
préfèrent aller là je le vois plutôt que
chez des personnes qui sont allés le
matin Rungis ce voilà donc on voit bien
que ça il y a une appétence
que les gens cherchent d'abord
effectivement
plus alors le bio il est beaucoup aidé
grâce à la loi egalim parce qu'il y a un
pourcentage obligatoirement de bio dans
les cantines est-ce que vous trouvez que
dans les restaurants je sais qu'il y a
beaucoup de restaurants qui font du
local à Fontainebleau mais est-ce que la
loi devrait peut-être imposer aussi au
restaurant de faire du bio pour
encourager pour aider cette filière là
2% Brigitte dans les restaurants le
mieux c'est très peu oui je sais pas si
il faut aller jusqu'à obliger les
restaurateurs je pense que les
consommateurs sont suffisamment
responsable pour peut-être privilégier
s'il y a une offre qui permet
effectivement d'accéder plats bio
d'aller privilégier ce restaurant donc
je sais pas s'il faut sur laquelle
normaliser jusqu'à obliger les
restaurants à dire il faut 15% 20% 30%
mais
ils le font chez moi je sais que par
exemple on a un restaurant étoilé à
Fontainebleau il a le souci de dire que
c'est fromages viennent de la ferme de
là que alors tout n'est évidemment pas
en circuit court et en approvisionnement
local mais quand il y a des produits
qu'ils vont qui qui met à la carte il le
met en avant et je pense que ça fait
partie des choses que les les clients en
cherchent ouais et ce lotavorisme qui
s'est développé dans votre région est-ce
que c'est un vrai levier de croissance
pour la région ou pas ou finalement qui
vendent à Rungis ou à Marseille plutôt
qu'à Paris ou à Fontainebleau c'est la
même chose non je pense que c'est un
vrai levier de croissant d'ailleurs le
reportage le le couple enfin leur
portage le disait le couple qui lançait
le village potager l'exprimer je pense
que c'est c'est important aussi de ça
leur permet de produire dans des
circuits qui qui sont peut-être mieux
maîtrisés moins complexes moins lointain
que si effectivement il passait tout par
par Rungis et puis je le redis ça fait
sens aussi donc
non non je pense alors est-ce que c'est
un levier de croissance fort pour
l'instant on est sur le démarrage d'un
process parce que qu'on décrit là il y a
10 ans ça n'existait pas donc c'est
quelque chose d'assez récent on verra si
les filières tiennent si ça se développe
on verra on a vu que la ministre Olivia
Grégoire voulait mettre en place un
panier de produits avec à prix coûtant
est-ce que ça vous pensez que ça peut
fonctionner dans les frais dans les
supermarchés chez les distributeurs
est-ce que ça pourrait fonctionner et
aider une partie de la population qui
aujourd'hui a plus de mal à se nourrir
c'est une bonne idée moi je trouve c'est
une bonne idée je pense que
effectivement c'est c'est
très compliqué effectivement pour les
consommateurs de de se repérer dans ce
qu'il y a de bon dans ce qu'il y a
effectivement de de onéreux notamment
dans la dans la grande distribution
entre un peu les promotions entre leur
packaging parfois propre à certaines
marques de distribution enfin c'est vrai
que bon je pense que cette initiative
surtout dans des moments où
effectivement le sujet du pouvoir
d'achat est réel je pense que c'est une
bonne idée ouais alors la réforme des
retraites on va passer un tout autre
sujet à présent vous savez qu'elle était
en discussion à l'Assemblée mais quid
des agriculteurs sont-ils concernés leur
pénibilité est-elle prise en compte on
en parle et on met les pieds dans le
plat
Brigitte les métiers pénibles ne sont
pas la panache de l'industrie et du
bâtiment ils existent aussi dans les
champs les agriculteurs et les ouvriers
agricoles en savent quelque chose d'où
leur inquiétude face à cette réforme des
retraites les explications de Marco
pommier
triés ramasser les pousses de betteraves
soulevez des piles de caisse c'est le
quotidien de ces ouvriers agricoles si
la réforme des retraites est adoptée la
plupart d'entre eux devront partir plus
tard pour toucher une pension à taux
plein pour Loïc ça serait deux années de
plus à 42 ans c'est un coup dur j'ai mal
au genou j'ai un peu mal aux pieds j'ai
des problèmes un petit peu aux mains
justement la force de manipulation de
porter des charges et tout ça donc je me
dis à 60 et quelques années je sais pas
dans quel état je serai tous ne sont pas
logés à la même enseigne Pascal pourra
partir à la retraite dans 5 ans dès 60
ans un départ anticipé car il profite du
dispositif carrière longue il y a
beaucoup de personnes qui ont encore 20
ans 30 ans à faire et c'est certain que
pour eux ça va être compliqué ici a
Puget sur argent on travaille
directement sur cette machine agricole
et si les conditions de travail sont
moins difficiles qu'auparavant ces
ouvriers sont confrontés aujourd'hui à
une autre pénibilité les aléas
climatiques le travail n'est plus
spécialement difficile comme il était
donc à l'époque mais aujourd'hui
les changements climatiques font que la
pénibilité se reporte plus de ce côté-là
quoi donc on est obligé de surveiller un
peu plus de personnes l'été avec les
fortes températures pour lutter contre
l'usure professionnelle le gouvernement
mise sur un fond d'investissement doté
de 1 milliard d'euros objectifs
faciliter la reconversion mais pour la
FNSEA c'est l'encadrement médical qui
pose problème la visite obligatoire dans
le cadre de l'embauche aujourd'hui on
n'a pas les médecins et donc elle n'est
même pas assurée donc avant de de mettre
des moyens sur la fin de carrière il
faut le mettre tout au long de la
carrière pour justement accompagner nos
salariés et puis leur donner aussi des
moyens de se former d'avoir les bons
gestes la France compte aujourd'hui près
de 250 000 ouvriers agricoles
alors est-ce que ces agriculteurs ces
ouvriers agricoles tels qu'on les a vu
dans le sujet ils ont des raisons de
s'inquiéter est-ce que vous avez les
moyens de les rassurer ils sont comme
tous les Français et il se posent sans
doute les mêmes questions que les
Français qui se posent des questions
face à cette évolution
du régime des retraites donc ils ont pas
des raisons de s'inquiéter ils ont des
raisons définitivement d'essayer de
s'interroger sur les conséquences de la
sur les conséquences de de la réforme
maintenant
pour eux comme pour tous les français
si certains d'entre eux ont démarré
jeune par exemple et souvent dans ces
métiers là on démarre assez jeunes
c'est pris en compte et donc il y a
effectivement la possibilité enfin voilà
il y a certains vont peut-être partir
bien avant 64 ans parce que
si on démarre à 20 ans ils partiront
avant 64 ans donc
parce que c'est prévu dans la réforme et
que pour les carrières longues peut-être
un petit peu plus on sait que c'est un
point de négociation
lundi à l'Assemblée nationale donc je
vais pas dire que jusque là il y a
peut-être des choses qui vont bouger je
n'en sais rien mais s'il est possible
effectivement qu'il y ait encore des
espèces justement où vous pensez qu'il
faut rester avec je pense qu'il y a
encore deux trois points qui peuvent
effectivement bouger je vais vous en
citer tout ça mais nous on plaide bon si
on si on entend aussi on emporte gain de
cause pardon tant mieux mais sinon c'est
pas grave mais on plaide pour
l'insertion du close de revoyure dans
dans le régime des retraites pourquoi
parce que symboliquement c'est important
enfin symboliquement c'est important de
montrer avec ces choses de revoyeur que
le refaites l'origine des retraites
c'est un sujet qu'il faut en permanence
remettre sur le tapis quand j'ai en
permanence c'est tous les 5 ans tous les
10 ans en tout cas on le régime pas le
principe du régime par répartition c'est
qu'il est évidemment très dépendant de
la démographie de la situation
économique du pays
euh de de paramètres qui évidemment
change au fil du temps et que si on fait
une réforme des retraites aujourd'hui
c'est pas parce que ceux d'avant on fait
n'importe quoi et on corrige pas
simplement les les
erreurs c'est la situation elle évolue
effectivement et qu'à partir de la foule
ajuster souvent les Français moi je suis
frappé parce que en discutant avec des
gens les gens n'ont pas toujours en tête
que finalement ce qu'il cotise ce qu'il
paye aujourd'hui comme comme cotisation
permet de verser les les retraites
d'aujourd'hui il y a encore des gens qui
pensent que il y a encore des gens qui
cotisent pour eux et que finalement
quand ils vont tout
enfin regardez leur situation
personnelle on va leur dire ben voilà
vous avez cotisé tant et donc vous aurez
non ça marche pas comme ça et donc
évidemment que ils font en permanence
ajuster les règles et donc cette clause
de revoyure elle est importante pour
l'instant on n'est pas dans le texte
on pourrait dire que tout chaque début
de quinquennat repose la question après
évidemment les conditions font que le
sujet ouvert ou pas mais repose la
question d'une de où est-ce qu'on en est
où est-ce qu'on en est du régime virtuel
je pense que ce sera un rendez-vous
transparent pour les deux couleurs un
peu référendaire à l'élection du coup
non il y a pas que le sujet des
retraites qui qui fait qui fait
l'élection mais en tout cas on sait que
chaque nouvelle majorité chaque nouveau
président
en début de quinquennat et bien aura la
question aura à revoir la question des
retraites pour réformer parce que les
paramètres ont évolué ou au contraire
pour se satisfaire que les choses
peuvent continuer comme elles sont alors
dans cette réforme des retraites il y a
aussi la pension minimum à 1200 euros
85% à peu près du SMIC et ça c'est prévu
pour les agriculteurs depuis une
proposition de loi de d'André Chassaigne
le communiste 1200 euros
c'est pas énorme c'est pas beaucoup pour
quand on a travaillé toute la vie à la
ferme avec des horaires longs est-ce
qu'on vit bien aujourd'hui avec 1200
euros
qui est difficile ça dépend ça dépend de
votre situation personnelle ça dépend de
l'endroit où vous vivez aussi on vit pas
la même manière à Paris que enfin font
certains départements voilà cool la vie
n'est pas le même en France partout donc
est-ce qu'on vit bien avec 1200 euros on
vivrait sans doute mieux avec 3000 euros
mais le sujet n'est pas celui-là c'est
aussi la capacité de la solidarité
nationale à assurer une pension moyenne
je pense que c'est quand même un des
grands acquis de de la réformes à venir
et souvent qui est pas qui est pas mis
en avant parce que tout le monde
focalise sur le 64 ans mais sur l'âge de
départ là je légale du départ à la
retraite mais au-delà de ça il y a quand
même des mesures nouvelles sociales des
avancées sociales qui sont réelles et
cette pension minimum en est une par
1200 euros ça nous placera quand même
parmi les pays où la pension minimum est
la plus élevée
nos amis anglais ils sont en quelques
centaines d'euros pour la pension
minimum quand on fait des métiers
agricoles comme ça difficiles il y a
cette pénibilité dont on a parlé dans le
reportage on entend aussi la nécessité
de faire plus de prévention vous avez
été vous président de la FHF il y a
votre avis des efforts à faire de ce
côté-là pour avoir des avis médicaux des
rencontres avec un médecin plus
fréquentes pour j'entendais dans le
reportage que il était remarqué que dans
avec une médecine de du travail qui est
en souffrance et c'est vrai qui est en
crise
mais le problème c'est qu'on fait la
réforme pour les années qui viennent et
on espère que dans les années qui
viennent contenu d'un certain nombre
d'autres réformes qui ont été initiés
ces dernières années et qui devraient
continuer à l'être on aura de plus de ça
et aussi plus de médecins et aussi parce
que d'abord on forme aujourd'hui plus de
médecins donc il y a un moment ils vont
arriver je veux dire à maturité si on
voulait dire ça comme ça en fin de en
fin de cycle de de
enfin d'études donc il y aura plus de
médecins
mais c'est vrai que c'est important et
d'ailleurs c'est comme c'est comme les
les comment dire les visites médicales
obligatoires à différents âges de la vie
qui ont été mis en place là il y a
quelques mois
de financement de la Sécu évidemment que
ça marchera aussi à quand on aura plus
de médecins le nombre de médecin c'est
un sujet aujourd'hui ça va être encore
un sujet pour 5 ou 5 cette année les 5 7
prochaines années
mais ça ne devrait pas elle est réelle
cette pénurie pour pour médecine du
travail bien sûr la médecine du travail
en plus c'est des bêtises qui est pas
très valorisée c'est une médecine qui
est un peu le parent pauvre du système
de santé et il faut remettre des
médecins dans mon travail comme il faut
remettre aussi une infirmière dans les
établissements scolaires
médecine scolaire et ou des médecins
aussi donc il y a des parents pauvres
dans le système de santé la médecine du
travail en fait partie mais ça fait
partie des sujets qui vont évoluer avec
les les réformes en cours on parle de
conversion Brigitte et de changement de
carrière on l'a dit dans ce reportage
mais quelle perspective pour un ouvrier
agricole de 50 55 ans qui a passé toute
sa vie dans les champs à ramasser comme
on l'a dit des feuilles de betteraves
avec toute la pénibilité que c'est ça ça
peut engendrer qu'est-ce qu'on lui offre
comme perspective comme perspective s'il
veut continuer à travailler oui et de
changer de carrière bah après on peut
faire plein de choses enfin je veux dire
il peut se évoluer oui il y a d'autres
métiers je
oui mais il y a des races systèmes de
formation il y a un projet de loi qui va
arriver sur le le travail qui va avoir
un volet de d'accompagnement des seniors
effectivement pour effectivement changer
de métier être mieux formé assurer
faciliter les fins de les fins de
carrière professionnelle bon
il y a de quoi faire on manque on
parlait on parle de de on parle de
cuisine là moi je veux dire chez moi
tous les restaurants manquent à recruter
pour les métiers du service pour les
métiers dans les cuisines fabrication
pour voilà donc oui mais c'est des
métiers difficiles déjà ça si vous dites
un gars de 55 ans qui a travaillé dans
les champs vous allez maintenant passer
votre ville cherche aussi de la main
d'oeuvre tous les métiers de service
cherchent de la main d'oeuvre voilà donc
il y a de quoi faire il y a aujourd'hui
un besoin de main d'oeuvre c'est évident
alors puisqu'on a fini on va passer à
présent au dessert et c'est le péché
mignon
alors Brigitte voici le temps du sucré
avec un Fontainebleau quel Chauvin se
Frédéric Valcourt qui use mais vraiment
de tous les artifices pour nous faire
c'est sa vie
non à Fontainebleau moi je dis bravo
parce que le fontaine beau je connais
parce que j'ai quelques attaches à perte
en Gâtinais donc on en mange un peu à
côté de son tableau mais c'est vrai que
en dehors alors là c'est très locavore
comme dessert c'est pointu mais c'est ça
commence c'est un dessert méconnu
Brigitte mais très simple et très bon
parce que c'est une superposition alors
François il a sans doute une vision un
peu différent du Fontainebleau
normalement c'est superposition de
fromage frais là c'est assez rigide de
crème battue assez original c'est tout
blanc ça ressemble à un Fontainebleau
faut vraiment que ça soit marqué dessus
parce que à l’œil
revisité c'est Versailles ça doit être
ça
alors du coup alors comment ça se
prépare ça on fait on fait comment on
met du normalement c'est du fromage
blanc alors et ensuite de la crème
fouettée et normalement c'est c'est
présenté dans un peu de paraffine dans
une mousseline mousseline
en fait c'est une invention d'un crémier
bélifontin au 18e siècle qui
effectivement constatait que en amenant
le lait à la cour et donc en passant sur
des allées pavés sur des charrettes le
lait était secoué et donc déposer il y
avait une fine couche de de mousse on va
dire ou de crème plutôt qui était dépose
qui se formaient en haut et que les gens
mangeaient très vite avant que elle
retombe elle retombe et donc il a eu
l'idée effectivement de la fouetter de
fouetter le le cette crème et puis
progressivement pour l'aérer pour lui
donner effectivement un peu de de de de
volume et pour pas qu'elle retombe trop
vite effectivement on la mange dans un
voile de moustine mais c'est vrai que
c'est très compliqué le Fontainebleau
parce que ça produit à consommer tout de
suite et les restaurateurs souvent ils
aiment pas trop enfin peut-être que chez
vous il y en a plein mais on en trouve
pas beaucoup à la carte des restaurants
à Paris dans les restaurants c'est assez
rare vous en trouvez c'est très rare tu
as raison
un peu à Fontainebleau mais c'est très
rare en fait il faut aller chez des
fromagers qui le font le matin et que
vous consommez il y en a plein Paris qui
en vendent à Paris il y en a quelques
jours ils ont font tous
parfois dans la grande distribution avec
des marques alors artisanale mais ça là
il faut éviter
non parce que c'est vraiment ça se fait
à la main mais et dans les supermarchés
il y a rien qui se fait à la main
Brigitte je conseille de que vous le
fassiez c'est pas très compliqué vous
prenez un très bon fromage blanc vous le
mettez dans une petite coupe et ensuite
vous battez une crème et vous la montez
un peu en crème fouettée vous rajoutez
ça un peu de sucre et en voiture
l'intérêt aussi du Fontainebleau c'est
que on peut le mettre alors j'allais
dire à sa sauce non pas mais en tout cas
on peut on peut l'interpréter bon là
c'est un peu fade là il y a des filles
alors là je reprends pas du tout
nature avec du sucre avec un coulis en
général on le voit avec un coulis de
fruits rouges quelques fruits rouges
quelques fruits rouges ou quelques
filles
première avec des figuier de la menthe
c'est une première voilà mais souvent on
appelle aussi le Fontainebleau à fromage
un peu
battu comme ça bon normalement le
Fontainebleau le vrai Fontainebleau est
très très aérien et très léger ça n'a
rien à voir par exemple avec la crème
chantilly les gens dire ah oui c'est
qu'un peu non rien à voir rien à voir
est-ce que c'est fou c'est vraiment
fouetté il y a beaucoup de bulles d'air
et donc c'est très agréable parce que
c'est très très fin très léger et en
venant l'enquête j'ai découvert qu'il y
avait aussi un Fontainebleau salé alors
on peut le faire mais quand je disais on
le fait les les cuisiniers le font
parfois
en fromage en fromage en fromage donc
c'est les gens qui le mangent et avec
quoi en fromage un peu pour commencer
le boulot à côté ça apporte un peu de
on peut l'adapter on peut l'adapter à
différents usages mais voilà ce qui doit
marque caractériser le Fontainebleau
c'est le côté très aérien et très léger
ça compense le fait que c'est quand même
c'est pas très calorique c'est très
léger c'est voilà c'est léger au goût et
à l'oeil c'est quand même ça reste quand
même calorique et je mange maintenant je
mange mon dessert
notre invitation merci à vous tous de
nous avoir suivis merci à chez Françoise
évidemment qui nous a cuisiné comme à
l'habitude c'est mon petit plat on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de politique à table sur
LCP